welcome welcome into Market takes I know
you could have been anywhere in the
world but you're here with me I
appreciate that I am Dion rabone
reporter at the Wall Street Journal
today we are breaking down the latest
CPI the Consumer Price Index inflation
what's going on well inflation picked up
a little bit last month we are going to
explain what happened dig into the core
the causes talk about everything that's
going on with inflation prices all that
we're going to talk about what the
report showed the CPI report out this
morning really I think was unexpected a
little bit higher than expectations
we're going to talk about how we're
we're going to talk about those
expectations and why this report was a
little bit hotter than what economists
had expected we're going to give you the
major takeaways from this report talk
about how it aligns with the longer term
or even more recent term trends that
we've seen from inflation of course
we're going to take a look at the market
talk about what's going on with stocks
bonds we're going to talk take a look at
crypto this morning uh talk about
Commodities really all the reactions
we're seeing across the board to this
report we're going to talk about how
this influences the fed the Federal
Reserve how they're going to react to
this and how basically what they've said
comes in line or aligns with this report
of course we're going to talk about the
big takeaways and what comes next
because here at Market takes we are
always looking forward even though it is
backward looking data so let's get into
it right now let's talk about the report
I want to put a chart up here on your
screen so you can see just what we're
looking at CPI now this chart goes back
to January of 2021 and we'd seen CPI of
course inflation Rose see that high of
over 9% there in the summer of 2022 and
then through from then through 2023 we
see inflation moving in Just One
Direction that's down late in the year
in 2023 you see it start to kind of pick
back up but then you see it come down
again but what we see at the end of 2023
in December this report we see inflation
pick back up to 3.4% inflation actually
month over month rose. 3% a little bit
more than expected it was expected to be
3.2% so we what econ were predicting was
that Trend to continue moving lower
actually maybe move a little higher than
November but actually we moved quite a
bit higher or not quite a bit higher I
should say a little more than expected
3.4% versus November's 3.1% expectations
of 3.2% all that is to say inflation's a
little bit higher a little bit hotter
than what economists had predicted and
that's what we see in this chart and
really this just illustrates that
inflation had been moving lower
consistently now we're at that phase
where okay it might be coming back up
might be picking up a little bit going
back down but we seem to be staying
around this 3 three and a half% range
and that seems to be the theme let's
take a look at core inflation core CPI
throw that chart up here on your screen
now core prices is are when you exclude
food and energy so you take food and
energy out because those can be very
volatile they can move up and down a lot
in a month so taking those out you see
inflation has continued to kind of move
back lower but that's around the 4%
level and again the FED wants infl at 2%
fed doesn't want 3% inflation not 2 and
A2 the FED wants to consistently see a
trend of 2% inflation and what we are
seeing is that inflation has been a
little bit more sticky and core
inflation you see it kind of moving very
strongly back down again since the
summer of
2022 and now we're kind of getting stuck
around 4% on the core side this month
showing 3.9% right along with inflations
or expectations excuse me had been for
3.8% year-over-year year month over
Monon core prices rose. 3% that was
right align aligned with the
expectations from Economist so again
this chart just illustrating overall
trend moving lower but we seem to be
kind of running out of steam in terms of
getting inflation back down to the fed's
2% Target and the FED watches that core
number because they say that's more
predictive of where inflation's really
going it's more telling of the things
the FED can control of the things the
FED can influence and listen listen if
you watch Market takes if you watch the
economy if you watch the markets at all
you know it's all about the FED what the
FED does is really what's going to move
markets and when we got that big rally
in the stock market towards the end of
the year that was all based on these
expectations for inflation to keep
coming down for the FED to start
lowering rates this year as soon as
their second meeting of the Year this
report shows that there's a little bit
of uncertainty about that now there's a
little bit of well maybe inflation's not
coming down and maybe inflation's not
coming down as fast as you know folks in
the market had predicted and maybe there
could be a few more bumps in the road
going forward so let's talk about the
major takeaways from the report and what
we're seeing uh the big takeaway for me
when I read through this report when I
look at the numbers it's that this
Narrative of inflation just falling back
down to the fed's 2% Target that's being
challenged there's big questions about
that CPI showing 3.4% inflation in
December that actually goes against what
we saw from the pce report which is the
fed's favored gauge of gauge of
inflation now what the FED wants is 2%
if CPI is showing three three and a half
consistently it's staying above 3% it
means we're not getting to that 2%
inflation Target and it means the FED
really won't feel comfortable based on
what they've said in lowering and
cutting rates so we've got real rates
holding High holding about 2% but as
inflation picks back up those real rates
come down and then the FED doesn't have
that momentum two cut rates and let's
not forget there are some real Hawks on
the FED folks who want to keep rates
High who were very very worried about
inflation we'll talk about all that in
just a minute but the big theme the big
theme of this report is that inflation
The Narrative that inflation is just
going to come right back down really
smoothly really smoothly really quickly
to the fed's 2% Target that's being
challenged the market is reacting
accordingly we will talk about that in
just a sec but this report is going to
put a magnifying glass on all the future
measures of inflation more real time
things like gas prices grocery prices
rent prices uh restaurant prices all
those real-time indicators that folks
can watch there's going to be more of a
magnifying glass on okay are those
prices coming back down the big question
here is does this continue does
inflation stay stuck around three three
and a half% or does it start moving back
up again towards 4% because that again
is going to challenge the big picture
narrative it economists money managers
uh investors had all been betting that
the Fed was going to cut rates this year
and that was going to lead to some real
outperformance for the stock market that
the stock market was going to gain maybe
not as much as last year the S&P Rising
a little over 24% in 2023 but for the
FED to cut rates and for that to lead to
a big boost for the market see stock
prices rising higher if inflation
doesn't cooperate we don't get that and
that's what this is all about now at the
fed's last press conference you saw fed
share Jerome Powell talk about well you
know there had been a lot of talk about
getting inflation back down from 3% to
2% that's going to be the hardest part I
don't see it well he might be seeing it
now we're seeing inflation on CPI
actually not only not fall but rise
higher that's big and so that could be
momentous and we will hear from the FED
at the end of this month we'll be right
here on Market takes breaking it down
for you so it's going to be very
interesting and we've still got a little
bit of time before we get to that fed
blackout period uh which is two weeks
before their meeting on January 31st so
we could be hearing from some fed
officials and that could really move the
market you're going to want to watch out
for that uh shelter prices that's
housing all that those continue to rise
contrasting a lot of the real-time data
we've seen on rents so what we could be
seeing in CP is that even though overall
rents are slowing down and those price
increases are declining what people are
paying for their housing overall because
home prices keep Rising that's keeping
that high and economists have been
predicting for months and months and
months that this shelter component was
going to come down in a meaningful way
that we're going to start seeing lower
shelter prices and that's going to
really take the bottom out from
inflation and start to move inflation
lower we have not seen that and in fact
shelter prices up 0.5% that contributed
to half of the overall increase in CPI
another thing to watch is energy
year-over-year energy is actually
pulling the index lower so you're seeing
negative numbers from the energy
component so overall Energy prices are
lower than they were a year ago but
month over month what we've seen is
those Energy prices start to creeping up
start to creep up that's gas that's oil
that's utilities all those things in the
energy index in recent months those have
started to pick back up up 4% month over
month this month from November we have
seen consistently things like motor oil
and gasoline which had been down five or
6% over the last few months are starting
to pick back up and starting to move
positively again it's one month a one
month of Trend does not make but that is
something worth watching because the
price of energy the price of oil all
those things had been pulling inflation
lower now they're starting to push
inflation higher you're going to want to
watch that listen the big picture
takeaway here is don't sleep all right
let's check out now and let's talk about
what's going on in the market so I want
to throw a chart up here on your screen
from
wsj.com what you're seeing there are the
three major indexes you see we are
negative on all three for the day
initially you had the market kind of
start out higher and then I think really
investors started to parse and look
through this CPI report and say uhoh
this isn't good so you're seeing the Dow
the S&P the Nasdaq all lower the NASDAQ
actually holding up pretty well and
actually looking like it's kind of
picking back up big story here let's
take a look at the bond market because
that's what it's really all about want
to throw here check out what you have
the move from the 30-year Bond and
that's long-term inflation expectations
that's what that's all about soon as the
report was released boom you just see
this kind of Number the yield on the
30-year pickup jump like a rocket ship
then it came came back down as folks
started buying bonds saying okay maybe
this is overdone now you're starting to
see that pick back up again and you're
seeing a similar Trend here from the
10-year yield the most traded yield or
the most traded uh the most traded us
treasury note out there that's coming it
was way up now it's coming back down
investors not entirely sure what to make
of this check out here the Euro you're
seeing the Euro down which means the
dollar is up overall the US dollar Index
again you see a similar Trend right
jumps up after that report comes out
that's right here you just see a big
jump then it came back down and now
we're seeing it pick back up again you
could see that momentum really reach and
and kind of continue on for those things
like bond yields and the dollar moving
higher as more folks start to read deep
into this report these initial reactions
they really come just headline the
algorithmic uh trading machines that
folks have just kind of make a move oh
CPI is higher boom sell off bonds buy
the dollar then investors came in and
said H I don't know about this and as
they really read through the data I
think they're saying all right wait this
might be inflationary this might mean
rates are going to stay high for a while
let's buy the dollar let's sell bonds
that moves those yield prices higher
really quick want to talk about crypto
because Bitcoin is the big story of the
day SEC giving approval for those
Bitcoin ETFs I think we've got 10 being
approved and you see just a lot of
bullish momentum across the board you're
seeing green green Green Bitcoin cash up
about 11% almost 12% you got ethereum
classic up over 30% big moves in the in
the crypto Market you thought I would
have thought you might see a little buy
the rumor sell the news here but over
the past 5 days as the rumor of this
crypto ETF or this Bitcoin ETF being
approved was coming in you really have
seen some strong momentum Bitcoin could
be moving back towards 50,000 definitely
something to watch there on the
commodity space we're seeing oil higher
again we talked about it this is an oil
story it's an energy story we are seeing
oil prices continue to move higher
that's something you'll also want to
keep your eye on and again what we're
seeing in markets just really
illustrating right now the way investors
are responding the way investors are
thinking about how these things and the
effects of this inflation report could
move the market let's talk really
quickly about how this could move the
FED again at the December meeting fed
share Jerome pal said that he did not
push back on those expectations for rate
cuts the market is priced in a rate cut
at March that's the fed's second meeting
of the Year fed share pal in December
didn't push back on that he didn't say
Hey listen we're not doing that it's
absolutely not happening and the market
took that as a sign of okay it is
happening so those rates even after this
report was published even after we got
the CPI report investors still betting
on some rate Cuts as soon as March but
the bets have come back down a little
bit you're not seeing as much certainty
about it as you were really investors
have been pricing in about a 70 75%
chance we get a rate cut in March now
it's about a 65 66% chance but investors
still betting a rate cut is coming in
March and still betting we're going to
get six rate cuts by the end of this
year that that's a significant change in
fed policy and that's what investors are
seeing we will hear whether or not fed
officials come back and push on that
narrative uh in the coming weeks the
latest fomc meeting minutes though did
push back on that and we're going to
have to hear from some folks and again
we'll have that meeting January 31st
will'll be right here breaking it down
for you on Market takes big question as
we look forward is how committed is the
Fed to the 2% Target if you hear fed
share Jerome Powell come out and bang on
the table say we are committed we must
have 2% inflation nothing else will do
that could have a real impact on markets
he's not actually going to do that he's
not going to bang on any tables what I
mean is in his way right if you hear
some of those things if he's talking
really emphasizing the 2% Target that's
going to be a sign to markets uhoh maybe
this narrative is in question if they're
really committed that means rates need
to stay high that could push down
markets push down stock prices and that
could be a real hurdle for markets to
get over if they're not as committed if
they start to say well you know two % ah
you know it's getting there we're we're
in the right we're going in the right
direction things are looking all right
well that could add some more bullish
momentum to stock prices other risk
assets things like Bitcoin like
cryptocurrency that really thrive on
risk so what's next listen big questions
on things like real average earnings I
want to throw up one last chart here on
your screen and that's wages and this is
the Atlanta feds wage growth tracker and
what we have seen is Wages go up in a
major way in 202
2022 and then come down in a major way
in 2023 and what we've seen is that
Trend kind of petering off as we got
toward the end of the year and for four
straight months now wage growth has been
at 5.2% according to the wage growth
tracker all that means is Wages aren't
picking back up they're not Rising but
they're not coming back down either what
the FED wants to see is those wages
around three or 4% because fed share
Drome Palace said that's more in line
with uh inflation overall at three or at
2% excuse me wage growth around 3% means
inflation around 2% well wages are
holding around
5.2% what's the next step we haven't
taken that yet and again when this CPI
report came out we got the latest update
to the wage growth tracker once again at
5.2% so that really just illustrating
that wages are staying pretty stagnant
they're not moving up they're not moving
down and that's going to have a big
effect on inflation as well employers
are cutting hours we've seen that
consistently but the hours haven't gone
down below that 34.3 which is around the
long-term Trend if it falls below 34
that's going to be a big Market because
that is a huge long-term recession
indicator you want to keep your eyes on
that so what comes next PPI the producer
price index which is what businesses are
paying for prices that comes out
tomorrow we will get the retail sales
report on Tuesday January 17th Market
takes is going to be back to talk you
through the quart the fourth quarter GDP
report on January 21st January 25th
excuse me January 25th will be breaking
down fourth quarter GDP report and for
more check out my podcast wsj's take on
the week we cut through the noise to
explain the major business and financial
news that moves markets also you can
make smarter investing decisions
subscribe wherever you get your podcast
that's going to do it for us here on
Market takes thanks so much for tuning
in I'm Dion raoan reporter for the Wall
Street Journal we will see you when we
do it again next
time